hello and welcome to the Daily I'm Neil
Patterson and today we are once again
talking about immigration specifically
the total number coming here to the UK
under the previous government
immigration was far too high and the
system was badly out of control
net migration needs to come down
radically from hundreds of thousands a
year to just tens of thousands I know
that was David Cameron of course
speaking back in the first year of his
conservative government that was all the
way back in 2010 not that things had
improved one iota when Theresa May said
this and the election campaign of 2017.
so I think it is important that we
continue and we will continue to say
that we do want to bring net migration
down to sustainable levels we believe
that is the tens of thousands and not
one of you will be surprised to hear
what Boris Johnson was saying in the
election two years later I've said that
what we want to do is bear down on a
migration particularly of unskilled
workers who have no job to come to
success of conservative governments
including this one have promised to sort
it all out all the while the figures
have shown they've done nothing of the
sort and the data for 2022 is now out
they've literally just dropped I'm being
told that they are 606
000 net migration is six hundred and six
thousand people
on this episode we will be pulling apart
the data underpinning that eye-watering
record-breaking figure we'll be asking
why the conservatives continue to beat
this drum given her their record on
migration might play out at the next
election and we'll be seeing what if
anything can be done
whether it needs to be done
[Music]
well the data came from the office for
National statistics and comes with a
whole host of analysis graphs and
figures so I've handed those straight
over to our data and forensics
correspondent Tom Cheshire Tom good to
see you good to see you let's start with
the headline figure I mean it's
eye-watering but not perhaps as
eye-watering as some people had led us
to believe you know it's not a million
which is what had been uh promised by
some it is still huge this is still a
record for a calendar year more than 600
000 people so I don't think we should
lose sight of that just because it's low
than expected yeah I mean this is
perhaps the the best bit of expectation
management by the government since well
the local election results let's focus
though on where this 600 000 figure
comes from can we split it into EU
non-eu yeah and actually
um that's one of the things you do see
in the data is uh 2019 at the end of
that year that's the moment when non-eu
migration overtakes you and that's
obviously timing with the brexit and new
rules coming in I'm actually now
non-e-migration is actually negative so
more people are leaving than coming and
all that growth is coming from non-eu
migrations and then all those visas are
controlled by the government compared to
before with the EU when there was less
control over borders these are all visas
issued by the government people that the
government has allowed to come here so
so how fair is it to say then that
whilst the government has taken back
control they have used that control to
let in record numbers of people from
non-european Union countries yeah I
think that's exactly it okay we've got
the headline figure but do we know where
these people are coming from I mean
specifically of course talking here
about non-eu yeah in terms of non-eu
there's India is a really big one
Nigeria they've been really big drivers
of the growth in all sorts of years of
study and work visas too but yeah so
that's where you're saying that
non-e-migration uh coming from mainly
India and Nigeria that growth okay so
India and Nigeria understand that but we
are also seeing from Ukraine presumably
and because of the war but also from
Hong Kong because of that Chinese
takeover yeah I mean so last year that
was around 172
000. wow which was a jump on the year
before but at the start of that scheme
for Ukraine you had around 10 000 people
per week applying for that that's now
down to around 1 000 per week so that
has already come down headline figure
600k plus but in that figure we now have
Asylum Seekers included as well and and
running roughly what 70 76 000 I think
it was so that's part of the new
revision to this and why some of the
figures aren't directly comparable to
what they were before but yeah it is a
very small number in comparison and you
see that especially when we're talking
about uh non-legal migrations defined by
the government in terms of the small
boats they are very very small in
comparison to these legal routes which
the government certainly does have
control of just because there has been
an awful lot of chat about overseas
students they're dependent being a real
burden on this system and a big driver
of these figures what is that number in
terms of them can we put a specific
number I mean family accounts of six
percent of a non-eu long-term
immigration
um with an estimated 51
000 uh compared to 62 000 in 2021 so
that is already slightly smaller than
than it was um it's obviously something
the government feels it can control
because it still wants those students
obviously it's not restricting those
it's still got the graduate route for
students which I think has been
incentive that means students can stay
for two years afterwards if they're
working or looking for work in the UK
but again if we really zoom out
long-term pitch if you look at sort of
10 years down the line I think it's less
than 10 of people who come on a student
movies will end up staying so 10 years
later the vast majority of them have
left and then we really zoom out
um you know we're going squinting here
Global views yeah
um you know the UK population has
changed so two third maybe 10 years ago
15 years ago it was around nine percent
of the UK population was foreign born
today that's around 14 there has been an
increase but then if you look at it
compared to other countries especially
other oecd countries so countries you
know similar levels of economic
development UK has stayed in the same
place it's very squarely in the middle
of the pack it's slightly more than
France slightly less than Germany it's
nowhere near somewhere like Australia
which has a huge amount of immigration
so
um obviously there's a huge amount of
debate about this there's worth sort of
remembering we're very much in the
middle of the pack here so sort of the
idea that 600 000 plus is is the new
normal and that is what we should expect
from now until time and Memorial that
that doesn't wash yeah I mean forecast
for this has always been really hard but
it does feel that it's not going to be
permanently this time but it's not going
to be in the tens of thousands you know
as was promised many moons ago this is
going to be significant for a long time
going forward can we cope though I mean
when we were talking about net migration
and kind of the low hundreds of
thousands 200 250 000. you know the
argument that there was no room at the
end perhaps didn't wash as much as the
argument today when we're talking well
in excess of 600 000 people coming here
yeah I mean put it in perspective in one
year you've had a population roughly the
size of Glasgow added to the UK you know
glass goes around which country wants
Glasgow
yes uh but then watch yourself you're
not just talking about Glasgow a
beautiful city full of lovely people as
well and but you know to support those
lovely people you have a huge amount of
infrastructure you've got nine big
hospital sites you've got more than 100
primary schools you've got crucially
nearly 300 000 houses some of it may not
be too important so when we're talking
about migrants they tend to be working
age they don't put as much pressure on
the NHS versus the British population
does which is older they don't tend to
be children either compared to the
british-born population so that means
less pressure on schools especially
housing though 300 000 that's what's
required to house Glasgow right so
housing I think is one of those things
you really do have to look at and say
well if we do want to accommodate this
huge record number of people you need to
be investing in the infrastructure to
make that a smooth accommodation Tom
thanks very much thank you
probably a good time then to turn our
attentions to the politics of all of
this our political correspondent Ali
Fortescue is in Westminster look what
have we been hearing from the government
because figures this high at the very
least we know they're not where they
want them to be yeah they're definitely
not they were definitely trying to
distance themselves from these migration
numbers that was part of the reason
there was no Minister on the morning
round today and it was all pretty quiet
from the Home Secretary and the
immigration Minister we've just seen the
first kind of response really from the
immigration Minister Robert generic in
the House of Commons responding to an
urgent question from labor and he said
it was due to Temporary and exceptional
factors such as the UK's Ukraine and
Hong Kong bno schemes and this is key he
said the government is committed to
reducing migration whilst continuing to
benefit from skills and resources our
economy needs and there is a debate
going on in cabinet right now the heart
of government because there are those
like swella brovmen on one side that are
talking really tough on legal migration
and those like the chancellor that want
to open up migration to key sectors to
help with the workforce shortage and
that is a debate that's being had in
cabinet look you and I have both said
that the figures are not where the
government would want them to be so so
what is the government's policy on
migration there is this a plan to
restrict students coming here to study
bringing their dependents with them that
might have some effect but it certainly
won't come closer to reducing this
figure by hundreds of thousands so so is
it the case that this government is on
the one hand talking tough about
immigration but then also taking
advantage of the benefits that you get
from these incredibly significant
numbers yeah exactly and you know the
rhetoric is one thing the government
talking certainly very tough on illegal
migration and talking about cutting net
migration but the conservative has been
on a journey from talking about tens of
thousands under David Cameron and
Theresa May Boris Johnson talking about
getting the numbers to less than a
quarter of a million Rishi sunak last
week was effectively moving away from
that number so they're not setting any
Targets really they're just saying they
want to bring the numbers down it was
interesting I spoke to James Johnson
who's a former number 10 poster and he
was saying he thinks the government are
slowly moving from a position of talking
about the importance of reducing
immigration to controlling migration
um but for him he says there's a tension
between where the government are and the
public are because for the public and I
certainly saw this I was in um South
thanet yesterday
um they view illegal and legal migration
together really and they want to see
numbers coming down in some of those
Target conservative seats but look we're
not a country mile from a general
election are we at which immigration
legal or illegal will certainly be a big
old topic and you're going to have
people like Rishi sunak and indeed suela
Rwanda Braverman standing in front of
the British public talking incredibly
tough
but then the labor party will be able as
you've alluded to to point to every
general election since the conservatives
got in in 2010 when they have said
exactly the same thing we're going to
get it sorted we're going to get the
numbers down and they've done nothing of
the sort yeah and you know traditionally
conservatives have tended to poll better
with voters on immigration and I think
the conservatives have thought that
talking about it sends a message and the
fact that you know stopping the boats is
whatever she knocks top five priorities
are not one of kirst armors is something
that a few people have kind of brought
up when I've been speaking to members of
the public but the numbers firstly speak
for themselves and when it comes to
small boats the images of people
appearing on the Kent Coast is obviously
cutting through with some voters on
labor I mean they're not a million miles
from where the conservatives are they're
talking about cutting migration but
again they're not giving a specific
people they're talking about training up
British people to do jobs to tackle the
problems with Workforce shortage I mean
that is obviously swella Bravo's
language is pretty inflammatory at times
but that is similar to what she's been
talking about it is it perhaps possible
alley that whilst obviously
conservatively does have to speak to
their base they also have to speak to
the population at large and you know you
you look at this country and you compare
it to some of our literally our closest
allies just across the channel where
there are far right wing populist
parties running an anti-immigration
platforms we don't really have that in
this country is it is it perhaps
possible that the general public are a
bit more sanguine about migration to
this country than the conservatives
would have you believe
yeah I think that's a possibility and
you know the conservatives don't really
face much of a threat on the right
anymore yeah I mean Nigel farage ukip
they are not the the presence in UK
politics that they once went are they
yeah exactly I think they think that
that's a space they can fill and you
know we've seen them going big on the
kind of cultural Wars issues ahead of
the next election I think the worry is
that does that alienate some voters in
those lib Dem facing seats and I've
certainly
um spoken to people in places like Isha
Dominic Robb's constituency who have not
been particularly happy with some of the
language from the home secretaries and
the approaches to Illegal migration
things like the Rwanda policy
um so is you know labor being accused of
straddling the line is that actually a
better approach that doesn't alienate
people on both sides I think you know
immigration has always been a decisive
and divisive topic for decades but you
know finding the right answer isn't
necessarily straightforward
foreign
was saying a moment ago there don't
appear to be any easy answers to Sky
High net migration otherwise this
government would have taken them surely
nor is it immediately clear that
immigration on this level is necessarily
a bad thing so in an attempt to take
some of the heat out of the debate let's
adopt a rather more empirical approach
with Madeleine assumption director of
the migration Observatory at Oxford
University and also someone who advises
governments on immigration policy
Madeleine why is the net migration
figure for 2022 so so high
there are basically three things going
on at once and the fact they've all come
together at the same time is I think the
reason that we see this this peak now on
the one hand you have the war in Ukraine
and there were substantial number of
people who fled Ukraine and came to the
UK we then have a boom in recruitment of
international students now most of those
people are expected only to be in the UK
temporarily but in the short run they
still contribute to net migration as
they come in then the third factor is
people coming on work visas these
numbers have gone up and by far the
biggest factor in the increase is the
Health and Care sector where we've seen
actually quite surprising increases in
their Recruitment and this will be both
doctors and nurses in the NHS but also
care workers coming in after the
immigration system was liberalized early
last year to make it possible for
employers to sponsor care workers from
non-eu countries just just remind us
about that because well this is under
the the skilled worker visa scheme that
we've been talking about actually indeed
on on the podcast this week and some of
the problems with it but when it comes
to the care sector not much in the way
of qualifications required certainly not
much in the way of salary but there is a
massive gaping hole in the care sector
that these these people are coming to
fill that's right and there's evidence
that there have been really serious
shortages in the in the care sector that
was not just because of the end of free
movement there are a lot much longer
term factors including a funding model
that effectively sort of bakes in the
minimum wage for many care workers so in
part in response to these shortages the
government liberalized the immigration
system early last year and what's really
interesting is that the response has
been very significant in 2022 alone the
home office is estimating around 57 000
people were given care visas and so it
looks like actually the numbers of
people coming in under the new regime
greatly exceed the number of EU citizens
who were coming to do care work at
before brexit
am I right then to assume from from what
you're saying Madeleine that if you know
if payslow in this sector and you know
and I did the conditions are difficult
then then one way that we could bring
down net migration to this country is by
increasing the amount that we pay people
working in the care sector
yes broadly speaking I think that that's
true there is some uncertainty about
exactly how much you would have to pay
in order to to attract a lot of British
people into the job it's clear I think
that most people want more than the
minimum wage to do care work because it
can be difficult it's stressful and this
comes to one of the core trade-offs that
we actually see in a lot of areas of
immigration which is that it comes down
to policy choices you could invest a lot
more money to improve paying conditions
and attract more workers into the sector
obviously that comes at a cost and the
funding of social care has been really
controversial for uh for years now but
in the long run I think it's difficult
to see at a long-term solution that
doesn't involve some increases in pay as
you're well aware since the
conservatives got in in 2010 we have had
Litany of different ideas from different
Prime Ministers about where the net
migration figure should be and and
targets bring it down underneath and and
all the rest of it I mean is it possible
to quantify an ideal number a net
migration Target that would fill all the
needs that we have in this country and
not overlay burden housing burden the
NHS and so on is it possible to pick a
number as a Target and and stick to it
um basically I think no for two reasons
one is that it's actually difficult for
governments to guarantee a specific
number of people because policy
typically doesn't dictate exactly the
number of visas that will be issued
policy dictates who's eligible right so
doctors and nurses are eligible or care
workers are eligible or International
students but the number of people who
take up that offer will often change
sometimes quite substantially even if
policy is the same the broader issue is
you know how would you pick that number
if you did want to guarantee a Target
and I think economists tend not to have
a view actually on what the right level
of migration is because ultimately the
economy adjusts to the number of people
who are in it and it often just comes
down to these policy choices I suppose
that there are two questions that need
to be answered first can net migration
be significantly brought down through
public policy and secondly is that
desirable do we want to see the numbers
calm down or or is it still the case
that immigrants to this country are net
contributors to the economy
think so announced with the first
question can the numbers be brought down
through public policy yes I think they
can as I mentioned uh you know there's a
reasonable expectation nothing is ever
guaranteed but there's a reasonable
expectation that the numbers might come
down anyway even without any changes in
policy but by all means the government
could decide to be more restrictive in
any number of barriers if it wanted to
you know in the area of Health and Care
for example it could say that it wanted
more restrictions there and wanted to
increase training or paying conditions
domestically instead the question
whether it's desirable is one where
reasonable people will disagree and I
think it will depend on the specific
routes you're you're looking at and I
think the overall challenge that
governments face is that even where
there's a desire to bring down overall
migration numbers from people who are
looking at the headline figures
sometimes the the constituent parts that
actually make up that migration can be
reasonably popular and so it's not
necessarily easy to find areas to to cut
without any consequences or without
people disagreeing I mean it it is still
Fair though to say that the British
economy to an extent relies on migration
relies on workers coming from overseas
to this country it's just difficult to
to put that side by side with some of
the rhetoric that emerges from from the
right wing of the ruling party the
conservatives I think that I mean it's
certainly true that many employers have
a business model that is very reliant on
on migrant workers if you take something
like seasonal work I think that's an
industry that basically couldn't survive
in its current form without seasonal
workers coming from from overseas I
think nothing's inevitable though I I
think I'm slightly skeptical of
suggestions that we simply need a
certain number of people because it
always comes down to to choices often
outside of immigration you know so in
the case of the soft fruit industry very
labor-intensive industry I think the big
question there is there's no optimal
number of raspberries that the UK needs
to be producing right it sort of comes
down to actually questions that are not
really about immigration policy of you
know how how big a food production
industry do we want in this country and
they're I think reasonable people will
disagree
Madeleine your job as director of the
migration Observatory it gives you the
perfect positions from which to answer
this question do you do you think that
we have a genuinely informed
conversation and debate about migration
in this country depends what you mean by
genuinely informed
there's a lot of data and I think it is
I think legitimately it's quite you know
it's very complicated and it I think
it's quite difficult sometimes for
people to understand the complexity of
migration so if you take something like
today you know you may have reasonably
high quality statistics and people can
talk about what those data mean but
underneath the headline figures you know
whether it's 606 000 or anything else
there are many many different policies
Each of which is sort of technically
quite complex that contribute to all of
that and so I think it is inevitable
that you know some of that really
important detail gets gets lost to the
overall discussion do you think we will
ever get down to the tens of thousands
as David Cameron promised all those
years ago
[Music]
in 2020 because of the Kobe pandemic I
think that's the kind of thing that gets
you below a hundred thousand I I don't
see the numbers getting down to that
kind of level without some you know
really significant change to the entire
model you wouldn't get to that sort of
level but just trimming around the edges
well I will keep my fingers crossed that
swella bravman does not propose a global
pandemic to try and bring down the
immigration numbers in future
my thanks to Madeleine assumption Ali
Fortescue Tom Cheshire and of course to
you for listening to the Sky News Daily
with me Neil Patterson this episode was
produced by Rosie Gillett our editor is
Philly Bowman